[Music]
in a place like MIT you have people from
all over the world from very different
backgrounds ethnicities and races and
cultures and the ome is a place where
you can find people that probably have
your same background in my case there's
one of those Tov members those Puerto
Ricans so that's always nice for me to
go in and just talk to her there open
arms no matter who you are where you're
from at the core of this mission to make
the world a better place
is empowering students with that mindset
with that mind at hand mind setting
giving them the tools that they need in
order to be effective in that mission
and the army plays a distinctive role in
that and making sure that these students
are successful for many students they
find within the OMA that this is the
community that becomes for their home we
have a portfolio of about 25 different
programs that really do help students
navigate MIT but also think about what
they want to do beyond MIT I struggled
in physics when I was an undergrad and I
really never had any sex in high school
so when I came to when I came to MIT it
was like F equals MA and I was like mind
blown it takes a little bit of momentum
at times to give students to overcome
their natural reluctance to say I don't
understand this I need some help with
this success and successes the Army has
given it to me is all about confidence
and feeling like you understand your
environment
you